I want to make a quick follow on really
correction to my second oxidation video
I was pointed out that I made an error
that you will probably find confusing so
I had written down hydrogen peroxide
because this was one of the situations
or the special cases for where oxygens
oxidation state isn't necessarily -2 so
hydrogen peroxide is two hydrogen's two
oxygens and its structure looks like
this the oxygens are bonded to each
other and they're each bonded to a
hydrogen and we know oxygen is really
electronegative it likes to hog
electrons and I said that in that video
and because it hogs electrons the
hydrogen's lose their electron to oxygen
or at least from the oxidation state
point of view so they each have a plus 1
oxidation state which I did say in that
video and then I went on and my brain
was curly and this is actually a good
point for you to realize how confusing
this can sometimes be if you're not
careful with your work you know I say in
the last video and obviously oxygen
gains an electron and then I say and
it's oxidation state is plus 1 and which
clearly makes no sense if you gain an
electron that will reduce your oxidation
state it will reduce that hypothetical
charge and so your oxidation state is
minus 1 in each of these oxygens and of
course this is a special case because
traditionally oxygen and the case I
always show it with is with in water is
that when it takes two electrons one
from this hydrogen one from that
hydrogen it normally has an oxidation
state of minus two and of course in this
case it's plus one and plus one for the
two hydrogen's I think I what later when
I figure molecular form and I kind of
corrected it in my head but I want to be
very clear to you oxygen does not have
an oxidation state of plus one in a
hydrogen peroxide it is minus one I said
it gained the electrons but then my
brain obviously heard the word gaining
and wanted to put a plus sign there no
it gained an electron that reduces the
oxygen it makes this oxidation state
minus 1 for hydrogen peroxide so
hydrogen peroxide has two hydrogen's
with a plus one oxygen a plus one
oxidation state and
has two oxygens with a minus 1 oxidation
state 1 times 2 minus 1 times 2 is equal
to 0 so we're all cool